Музыка Hallo, herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge, das Podcast Ufo mit mir, Stefan Thiese, und dir, Florian, danke, dass du es einrichten konntest. Ja, klar, ist doch gerne, ich komme aber gerne rum. Wir waren gerade noch so gefangen im Intro, ich habe überhaupt nicht daran gedacht, dass wir heute überhaupt noch einen Podcast aufzunehmen haben. Ich war so gefangen in meinem eigenen Körper, der versucht hat, seine Gefühle auszudrücken, primär durchs Gesicht. Ja. Kennst du diesen Tanz? Ich habe diesen verwirrten Tanz gemacht, dieses, wo geht's hin? Wo geht's hin, aber dieses ironisch distanzierte Was passiert denn hier und dann kommt der Drop und dann wo ist der Drop, ah ja ja ja ja ja, dieses wissende Tanzen. Vielen Dank an Anton für dieses fantastische Intro und diese kleine Reise durch eine musikalische Emotionalität, die wir sonst so nicht haben im Podcast. Frage an dich, glaubst du, er hat angefangen Musik zu machen, der Anton, weil das Wort Ton in seinem Namen drin ist und er so subversiv immer wasiv immer was durch den Namen mitbekommt auf seinem Lebensweg. Ich glaube, ab einem gewissen Punkt muss man einfach einsehen, dass man einfach dafür gemacht ist. Wenn du tierlieb heisst, dann musst du einfach ein Zoo gründen. So ist das nun mal, das sind die Regeln unserer Dimension. Deswegen, glaube ich, kommt man da nicht umhin. Nomen est omen, sage ich ja oft. Das sagst du zu oft, finde ich. Und viele meiner Freunde und deiner Freunde sagen das auch. Und deswegen gerade eine Intervention. Ihr habt mich mal hingesetzt und gesagt, Florentin, so geht's nicht, du hast kein Latinum erstens. Ja, ich habe zehn Seiten langen Brief verfasst auf Latein. Wir wissen nicht, ob das überhaupt legal ist, ob du dein Latinum, du hast mir deine Latinum-Karte gezeigt, die du im Geldbeutel getragen hast. Latein ist tot, ist eine ausgestopene Sprache, weil ein Meteorit alle Texttafeln kaputt gemacht hat. Latino mortis est. So, wie gesagt, es reicht. Nee, aber ich frage mich manchmal, was war zuerst da quasi die Idee oder der Name? Nee, frage ich mich nicht, weil der Name war immer zuerst da. Aber neulich habe ich die Tagesschau geguckt und da war ein Beitrag über Münster, weil die als gutes Beispiel gezeigt wurden, weil es da eine geringe Inzidenz gerade nur gibt. Und der herzlichen Glückwunsch an Münster. Und dann war der verantwortliche Politiker da, hieß auch Münster mit Nachnamen. Und das Wort Münster fiel in diesem Beitrag über Münster so häufig, dass es fast lächerlich war. Und es blickte fast wie so ein Sketch. Herr Doktor Münster, Sie sind Professor in der Münzner Universität in Münster. Wie sehen die Inzidenzen in Münster aus? Ja, genau so ein bisschen war es so. Und es war so ein bisschen so ein, es wirkt wie so eine Challenge, wie so eine Wette. Wie oft kriegen wir das Wort Münster in diesem Beitrag über Covid unter? Und die Antwort ist ja. Ja, das stimmt. Man sollte aber bei seinem Kind auch aufpassen, dass man sowas wirklich anlegt, also so ein Story-Ark einfach mal anlegt, dass man ihn einfach Ulm nennt, einfach Ulm will und der dann einfach sich immer fragt, warum heisst ich Ulm? Vielleicht sollte ich einfach mal in diese Stadt fahren. Einfach mal nach Ulm und dann mal gucken, was da los ist und dann einfach mal rumfragen und dann sagen die Leute sich, ah, wir haben nicht erwartet. Warum, warum? Und dann verschwindet er wieder in den Gassen und dann weiss man nicht. Und dann plant man im Vorhinein für sein Kind schon dieses riesige Abenteuer, so eine Art Lab, nur halt in Ulm. Ich nenne meinen Sohn Schauspieler oder meine Tochter Schauspielerin. Einfach um so subtil Hinweis zu geben, was ich möchte, was sie werden. Ja, das wäre eine gute Idee. Mal schauen, ob es klappt. Schauspielerin Tietze. Oder Was Solides Tietze. Finde ich ja ganz gut. Was Solides.. Was Solides, ich kann dir echt eine gute Ärztin empfehlen, das ist die Schauspielerin Titel, die ist wirklich fantastisch, da kann ich gut hingehen. Nee, will ich nicht hingehen. Sie hören von meiner Anwältin, Schauspielerin Titel. Eigentlich auch gut, also ich habe mir letztens überlegt, will ich einen guten Anwalt oder will ich lieber zwei billige Anwälte? Also nicht, dass ich einen brauche, also keine Angst, aber ich habe mir echt überlegt, ist es nicht sinnvoller, sich zwei billige Anwälte zu suchen, damit man sagen kann, sie hören von meinen Anwälten, dass du einfach den Plural hast. So, aber dann würde ich einfach einen guten Anwalt nehmen, eine gute Anwältin und dann noch einen billigen. Ja. Weil dann kannst du es trotzdem sagen. Ich glaube, du bist auch auf der Safe-Seite des Rechts. Ja, aber die Frage ist, was ist budgetär? Und außerdem fände ich das ungerecht, wenn jemand, der sich als Discount-Anwalt verkauft, dann mit so einem Top-Anwalt zusammenarbeiten muss und einfach sagt, Leute, ich habe hier keine Chance. Warum machen wir nicht einfach eine Anwaltskanzlei auf, die einfach nur heißt, wir können nichts, also die Webseite ist einfach leer, wir können nichts.de, aber wir sind quasi das E in eurem, ihr hört von meinen Anwälten, wir sind das Plural, wir sind das Plural, wir sind sehr günstig, dafür sind wir das Plural und wir machen auch nicht viel, also klar, du musst ja immer, wenn du so in den Gerichtssaal reinkommst, hast du ja dieses Spalier an Anwälten hinter dir. Da haben wir viele
Praktikantinnen und Praktikanten mit
Aktenkoffern, die kommen da ran,
aber es ist super billig, richtig billig.
Finde ich den ganz gut. Wir sind der
oder das Plural,
je nachdem, wie es richtig ist.
Plur.al.
.günstig.schnell.
Diese Domains
sind auch irgendwann ausgeraten.
Finde ich jetzt nicht so schlecht, ehrlich gesagt.
Nee, finde ich richtig gut. Alles ist besser im Plural. Einfach wenn du sagst irgendwie, ja, ich bin unterwegs mit meinen Freunden, dann besuche meine Anwälte und ich habe letztens wieder mit meinen Ärzten gesprochen. Man hat direkt so, wow, du hast so einen ganzen Stab in deinem Leben, wohingegen so Einzelsachen sind. Ich habe neulich die härteste Mail geschrieben, die ich jemals in meinem Leben geschrieben habe.
Und ich musste die ganze Zeit dabei grinsen, wo ich dachte, man braucht auch so eine Art Boxsack oder so einen Stressball im Sinne von Mails. Also eigentlich so eine Mailadresse, wo man so eine Mail hinschicken kann. Einfach um so ein bisschen Stress, weil ich hatte richtig Spaß dabei. Hintergrund ist nicht so toll. ich bin auf meinem Ticket sitzen geblieben, mein Formel-1-Ticket von einem Rennen, wo ich nicht hingehen konnte, wegen der aktuellen Lage. Stefan, du bist echt einer, der am härtesten getroffen wird. Ich muss mal schon sagen. Es tut mir echt leid für dich, dass du nicht zu deinem Rennsport gehen konntest. Ja, wo Autos mit Benzin im Kreis herumfahren. Zu deiner Belustigung. Zu meiner Belustigung. Also muss man schon sagen, ich habe mit dem härtesten getroffen dieses Jahr und dann habe ich das Geld nicht wiedergesehen. Kein Penny, keine Penunzen. Und habe den jetzt mal geschrieben und ich kriege lustigerweise immer die Antwort, nee, wir brauchen noch ein bisschen, brauchen noch ein bisschen, brauchen noch ein bisschen. So beim achten Mal, wir brauchen noch ein bisschen, habe ich geschrieben, bitte überweisen Sie mir sofort das Geld, sonst sehe ich mich dazu gezwungen, rechtliche Schritte einzuleiten. Wow. Was die härteste Mail ist, die ich jemals geschrieben habe. Ja. Sonst sehe ich mich in der Lage, sonst sehe ich mich gezwungen, rechtliche Schritte einzuleiten. Und jetzt definier mal genauer rechtliche Schritte. Ich hoffe, dass diese Mail nicht zurückkommt. Definieren Sie rechtliche Schritte. Was meinen Sie damit genau? Dann komme ich sofort ins Strudeln. Ich zeige es dir an, wegen Geld zurückhaltend. Verneumdung. Gib mir das BGB. Schnell, schnell, irgendeins, irgendein Paragraf, irgendein Paragraf, weißt du, jetzt 208. Da fände ich ja auch geil, wenn ich jetzt zwei billige Anwälte hätte, sie hören sonst von meinen Anwälten. Sie hören sonst von meinen spottbilligen Anwälten. Von meinen spottbilligen Anwälten, die ich habe und dann weiterleiten Plural. Also so wie ich die kenne, werden sie wahrscheinlich nicht von denen hören, weil sie a die falsche Telefonnummer anrufen und an die falsche E-Mail-Adresse ihre E-Mails schreiben.
Also sie werden nicht von meinen Anwälten hören.
Aber ich sage nicht so, wie, also rein menschlich jetzt mit denen war es das ja jetzt, ne?
Ja.
Weil, wie komme ich von dieser Mail wieder auf eine ... Aber du bist auch sehr aggressiv bei Kundensupport, ne? Das ist ja wirklich ...
Nee, gar nicht.
Naja, aber das klingt jetzt für mich schon nicht übergrifflich.
Wie gesagt, ich bin super, super nett die ganze Zeit gewesen, aber dass die jetzt fast ein Jahr lang, das ist schon ein bisschen länger her, das Geld nicht zurückzahlen, fand ich schon ein bisschen dubios, ist jetzt auch so eine merkwürdige Dritte anbieterseite gewesen, aber alles nicht so ganz koscher. Und jetzt weiß ich halt nicht genau, wie man damit umgeht. Und dann wurde ich dann irgendwann tatsächlich sauer. Normalerweise bin ich sehr nett im Kundensupport. Wie sieht das aus? Du sitzt zu Hause bei dir in der Wohnung, vor dem Laptop
und bist sauer?
Haben wir Kopfhörer auf, haben wir einen Drink,
haben wir einen Kaffee in der Tasse?
An diesem Punkt war ich so sauer, wir haben keine
Sekundärmittel
am Start. Hast du
einen Bleistift in der Hand, mit dem gespielt wird?
Auf dem ich kaue.
An diesem Punkt war ich einfach nur
sturzbetrunken, rauchend in meiner Wohnung und habe mich einfach nur aufgeregt. Er wurde die Wohnung demoliert. Die Wohnung demoliert und saß dann da in diesem schimmerigen Halbdunkel und wusste nicht sonst wohin mit meinen eigenen Problemen, als sie nach außen zu schieben. Ja. Und hat dann diese arme Kundenhotler hat es erreicht. Finde ich aber auch nicht schlecht. Stressmail.de, einfach eine E-Mail-Adresse,
an die man richtig saftige Mails schicken kann,
einfach um es Leuten gesagt zu haben.
The Punching-Back-Mail.
Ja, Punching-Back-Mail, damit man es nicht den Leuten sagt.
Meine Erfahrung natürlich, ich habe ja auch lange im Kundensupport gearbeitet,
ist natürlich, dass man mit Freundlichkeit weiterkommt.
Und deswegen würde ich allen raten,
aber nee, dass du jetzt einfach nicht,
dass du deinen sportbilligen Anwalt anrufst und sagst,
ja, guten Tag, Herr Gesetz, dass du jetzt einfach nicht, dass du deinen sportbilligen Anwalt anrufst und sagst, ja, guten Tag,
Herr Gesetz, ich würde gerne rechtliche Schritte
einleiten. Naja, erstmal ist es ja eine super
leere Drohung. Das wissen die, das weiß ich,
ich habe aber bis heute keine Mail zurückbekommen,
das ist irgendwie jetzt auch schon drei Wochen her,
also ich dachte mir, was kommt jetzt da zurück?
Ja, der kommt zurück, come at me,
bitch. Ja, genau. Vor allem ist es,
ich habe die Formel 1 angekackt, das sind die reichsten Menschen der Welt. Ja. Und die sind auch schwer zu fangen. Die sind schwer zu fangen. Ja. Rechte, die ist rückte Einfall. Ja, da können wir leider nichts machen. Ja, da können wir nichts machen. Also die sind auch schwer zu fangen, glaube ich. Also du willst dich nicht mit denen anlegen. Aber die fahren auch nur im Kreis. Das sind die schnellsten und reichsten Anwälte. Aber drehen die eigentlich auch mal um? Oder wird man nicht blöd, wenn man immer nur noch links fährt im Kreis? Für die Reifen vor allem blöd, weil es immer eine Seite schlimmer trifft als die andere Seite, weil eine Seite der Reifen mehr belastet wird als die andere Seite. Und könnt ihr nicht sagen, die ersten fünf Runden nach links und dann nach rechts die nächsten fünf Runden? Kann man nicht sagen, nee. Ist aufwendig.
Das heißt, du fährst, also...
Das würde auch die Fans verwirren.
Aber gibt es dann auch wirklich Fahrer, die besser nach links fahren?
Oder sind alle Strecken der Welt so, dass man nach links fährt?
Nee.
Manche fähren auch nach rechts.
Manche sind auch gegen den Uhrzeigersinn.
Und gibt es dann auch Fahrer, die spezialisiert sind auf links Strecken oder rechts?
Es gibt Fahrer, wo man merkt, ah, links.
Näh, das ist eher so.
Das ist eine linke, eine linke Strecke ist das. Gute Frage. Ich weiß nicht, ob es gerade stimmt, dass alle immer im Monzeiger sind und vielleicht gibt es keine. Geisterfahrer sind ja eher ein Problem dann, glaube ich, bei der Formel 1. Geisterfahrer sind generell ein großes Problem. Ja, ein Riesenproblem. Das ist das schlimmste Problem. Ein Riesenproblem, als ich noch früher viel Verkehrsradio gehört habe, ständig Geisterfahrer. Und das ist auch meine grösste Angst im Verkehr, ist selber zum Geisterfahrer zu werden. Ist selber schön, über die Autobahn zu fahren, falsch rum. Und da habe ich einen kleinen Witz. Okay, ich bin bereit. Dann schliess mal los. Hier folgt mit der Startnummer 15 Florentin für Deutschland mit seinem Witz. Also ein junger Herr fährt auf der Autobahn, unspektakuläre Reise bisher, fährt noch Ulm, je nachdem, ist unterwegs und denkt sich, Mensch, das zieht sich aber ein bisschen, diese Fahrt. Ich hätte gedacht, es geht schneller. Und er entscheidet sich, das Autoradio anzumachen, dreht am Knopf, findet bald daraufhin einen Radiosender und hört Musik und, ja, wie sagt man schon, Sprechradio im weitesten Sinne und plötzlich kommt es zu einem
Bip, Bip, Bip,
ihre Verkehrsdurchsage und
er hört,
sagen wir mal, er ist jetzt auf der A8 unterwegs
und er hört im Radio
Vorsicht,
Geisterfahrer auf der A8,
ah ja, gesichtet, die wo er ist,
und er
schaut etwas verwundert auf,
schaut um sich und bemerkt,
wie ein Geisterfahrer
Vielen Dank. Ah ja, gesichtet, die wo er ist. Und er schaut etwas verwundert auf, schaut um sich und bemerkt, wie ein Geisterfahrer. Hier sind überall Geisterfahrer. Wow. Der Gag an dem Punkt ist, dass die Erwartungshaltung gebrochen wird. Das war Florentin mit der Startnummer 16 für Deutschland. Wow, und das war wirklich eine tolle Performance. Jetzt gleich folgt Malta. Malta schickt eine ganz junge Joke-Erzählerin an den Start. Wir haben hier Malta mit Clarissa. Sie hat das Clarissa für Malta. Sie hat den Vorentscheid in Malta gewonnen und ganz Europa war begeistert. Ihr Witz ging sogar viral. Und bei den Buchmachern ist Malta mit ihrem Witz ganz weit oben. Wir freuen uns also auf Stadt Nummer 17, der große Favorit, Clarissa mit ihrem Witz. Viel Spaß. Er wurde der Werbe oder wie man auch immer auf Malta spricht. Jan, war das Englisch? Keine schlechte Idee, der Eurovision-Joke-Contest könnte man auch machen.
Welches Land ist am lustigsten?
Und einfach dann wirklich so, endlich ein... So awkward Leute hinschicken.
Ja, endlich mal ein Contents, wo es niemand mehr verwirrt, dass wir auf dem letzten Platz sind.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Aber da wird sich die Frage, wer hat da am meisten zu verlieren, welches Land?
Ich glaube, die Engländer gelten als sehr, sehr witzig, sehr, sehr ulkig,
Monty Python und
Queen und so,
sehr lustig, trockener Humor.
Silly, aber auch silly,
Humor. Ja, silly, aber auch trocken.
Aber beides. Also wir
wollen beide nicht wegrücken von
unserem Wort. Nein, ich
bin der Meinung, Engländer der meisten zu verlieren,
haben sie aber auch beim richtigen, Schweden, glaube ich, wäre nicht so stark, jetzt ohne Schweden zu nahe zu treten. Die Frage ist halt, wer ist die Jury, weil Humor ist ja auch stark länderspezifisch, also den klassischen, den Allgäuer Humor, den versteht man natürlich auch nicht irgendwie in Botswana, deswegen muss man da auch ein bisschen gucken. Ja gut, aber wer hätte gedacht, dass Lena auf dem Balkan so gut ankommt. Das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Hätte ich auch nicht gedacht. Hätte niemand gedacht. Hätte niemand gedacht. Deswegen, glaube ich, muss man es genau so machen. Also es gibt eine Humorfachjury in Deutschland natürlich bestehend aus Ralf Schmitz, Dieter Nuhr, Mario Barth, also alle, die es hier gibt in Deutschland. Und in anderen Ländern gibt es halt andere. Und dann gibt es aber auch einen Publikumsentscheid. Finde ich eine gute Idee, aber erzählen die Leute dann auch immer, also bei dem Eurovision Song Contest singst du den selben Song wie in der Vorauswahl, erzählen die Leute dann auch immer denselben Witz. Ein Witz, darfst du erzählen? Oder sagen wir fünf Minuten Stand-Up? Nee, wirklich ein Witz, ein knackiger Witz, damit man auch schön irgendwie in einer Stunde durchkommt. So, beim European Song Contest hängst du ja den ganzen Abend rum und du sagst ja, Mensch, ich wollte eigentlich noch in die Badewanne. Und so kannst du sagen, du hast 15 Länder, je ein Witz ist eine knackige Stunde und dann gehen wir nach Hause. Nee, nee, nee, da kommt ja erstmal der doppelt so lange andauernde Voting-Prozess, der natürlich genauso lang ist und ausufernd wie damals. Wo der Moderator mit den
einzelnen Kandidaten spricht und merkt, dass die
aussieht, ihre brillant hilarious
Performance sehr trocken, bierernste
Comedy-Professoren sind, die
wirklich da ganz fein gefeilt
haben, aber ansonsten nicht so lustig
sind. Ja, finde ich ganz gut. Also
ein Witz und der Gewinnerwitz wird
dann nochmal erzählt, was ich auch gut finde, am Ende wird dann nochmal eins zu eins so erzählt. Finde ich richtig gut. Lass uns das machen, lass uns mal verschiedene Länder anfragen. Du hast doch eh einen guten Draht zu Botschaften. Zu Ländern. Zu Ländern an sich, zu Botschaften. Lass uns mal gucken, ob wir da noch ein paar Länder unter die Fittiche kriegen. Das lustigste Land der Welt. Ja, stimmt. Ich habe ohne Scheiss den Botschafter Frankreichs in der Schweiz kennengelernt. Wirklich? Bei einem lustigen Abend. Und ja, der war sehr nett einfach und hat dann so angefangen mit mir zu quatschen. Und da war auch noch ein Kumpel da und haben mit dem ein bisschen gelabert und so. Wir wussten gar nicht, wer das ist, außer ein lustiger, sehr betrunkener Franzose, dachten wir. Und dann hat er uns, wollte er auch irgendwie unsere Handynummer haben, weil er hat uns noch auf so ein Schloss eingeladen. Wir haben das alles gar nicht verstanden. Wir dachten einfach, weird, rich, French guy. Und dann hat er uns irgendwann angefangen, so Links zu schicken. Also man sah auf seinem Handy, hat er so Bilder angeklickt, die er uns schicken wollte von seinem Haus und hat uns dann die bei WhatsApp schicken wollen. Das kam aber nur Links an. Wir haben schon so Gags gemacht, der alte Mann weiß nicht, wie man mit seinem Handy umgeht und so. Und dann war da so ein, wie sich später herausstellte, Leibwächter dabei, der meinte, nee, nee, nee, das sind Links, weil das ein Decoded Handy ist. Und dann kam raus, dass er der Botschafter von Frankreich ist und er uns, weil sein Handy encrypted ist, also so ein abhersicheres Handy, kann er uns keine Fotos schicken, sondern er schickt uns immer Links, dann klickt man da drauf und das alles so wahnsinnig abgesichert ist. Und dann wollte uns da dieser wahnsinnig betrunkene, betrunkene Champagner trinkende French Ambassador, wollte uns einfach Bilder schicken. Und dann haben wir erst geschickt, ah, okay, das ist der French Ambassador. Und man musste ihn die ganze Zeit Saint Excellence nennen, was ich auch nicht schlecht fand. Das ist schon geil, ja. Das ist schon geil. Ja, der hat halt diesen typischen, ein bisschen weirden Humor. Aber der stand dann auch für Frankreich. Also ihr konntet wirklich, der war stellvertretend für das ganze Land an diesem Abend. Ja. Und hat dann auch für Frankreich gesprochen. Ich spreche ja kein Wort Französisch und der hat am Anfang eine Rede gehalten. Mein Problem war nur, ich sass quasi mit dem Rücken zu ihm. Deswegen habe ich auch nicht gecheckt, dass der, mit dem wir uns danach unterhalten haben, der französische Botschafter ist. Das ist während der gesamten Rede nicht umgedreht. Ging nicht. Es ging einfach nicht. Es war quasi hinter mir fand statt, da haben sich ganz viele Menschen in den Flur gestellt, hinter mir war eine Wand und ich meine Couch, ich stand auf so einer Couch und da war ich in Blickrichtung weggedreht von ihm. Du standest auf einer Couch, ich saß auf einer Couch.
Und dann plötzlich wurde es sehr voll um mich herum,
hinter mir wurde angefangen, eine Rede zu halten,
in der Wand hinter mir herum.
So, und dann konnte ich dann nicht,
ich sah nicht, wer die Rede gehalten hat.
Aber ich habe die ganze Zeit während der Rede gelacht,
weil die verständlich war. Also es war, ich habe nach,
weil es war die ganze Zeit Französisch gesprochen,
und dann wurden Wörter wie Eiffelturm, also Tour d'Eiffel, Arc de Triomphe, Paris, Je t'aime, bla bla bla, wurde alles eingebaut und ich dachte mir so, ja, wenn ich eine Rede halten würde auf meinem Fake-Französisch, wäre es in etwa der gleiche Inhalt gewesen und musste die ganze Zeit grinsen, weil das so eine Klischee-französische Rede war. Ja, wie in so einem Sprachenlernbuch einfach wirklich, wo alle wichtigen Vokabeln drin sein müssen. Ja, oder wie, keine Ahnung, wenn in amerikanischen Talkshows Deutsch gesprochen wird, Wursten, Nachtzen, Bumsen mässig, so war halt auf Französisch diese Rede. Und dadurch kam ich, weil ich glaube, es hat ihn irgendwann irritiert, dass da jemand gelacht hat. Und dann kam man nachher so ein bisschen ins Gespräch und stellt sich raus, es war der Botschafter. Ich habe ihn nicht gesehen. Mega gut, aber das ist ja auch schon gut. Ich glaube, das mache ich jetzt auch. Links schicken immer, einfach damit man denkt, okay, krasser Typ hat ein verschlüsseltes Handy. Aber das ist auch so ein Punkt. Und da habe ich letztens auch wieder an unsere Sendung denken müssen, die wir nie gemacht haben, leider, aber die immer noch bei MTV auf dem Tisch liegt, wie lange würde es dauern? Wie lange würde es dauern,
wo man in verschiedenen Situationen einen Countdown
anmacht und einfach guckt, wie lange halten Leute
gewisse Situationen aus? Und ich glaube,
eine meiner aktuellen Lieblingssituationen, die ich auch immer
gerne wieder ein bisschen so unerträglich
hineinstrecke, ist das, oh, ich will dir mal, ich zeige
dir ein Bild, ich zeige dir ein lustiges Bild,
und dann sucht man auf seinem Handy,
und da würde ich wirklich gern einfach mal
den Timer anmachen, wie lange würde es dauern, bis die andere Person sagt, du, ich gehe jetzt. Weil man wirklich minutenlang scroll, scroll, nee, warte hier, nee, nee, das war doch, nee, das war vor dem letzten Jahr, glaube ich, im Sommer. War das ja, nee, da war ich auf Gran Canaria. Hoch, nee, war das im anderen Ordner und dann einfach die andere Person, weil es gibt keine Möglichkeit, aus diesem Gespräch wieder rauszukommen und das einfach mal so lange wie möglich halten und die Person kriegt einen Euro pro Minute. Da zeigen sich auch extrovertierte und introvertierte Menschen. Ja. Weil die Frage, wie man selber reagieren würde. Ich glaube, ich würde eine Woche einfach stehen und warten. Stehen und das einfach ertragen und über mich ergehen lassen und ich würde einfach Stuhl nach vorne gucken und man würde von außen nicht denken, dass sich in mir noch was rührt oder ich überhaupt noch ein Leben in mir habe. Aber kommt darauf an ein bisschen. Es gibt auch Menschen, wo ich sofort sagen würde, so, okay, danke, danke, ciao, okay, du willst ja zu mir auch sofort sagen, okay, ja, alles klar. Ja, klar, bei dir schon, aber es muss ja schon eine fremde Person sein, sondern man ist in der Firma und trifft einen Kollegen oder irgendwie sowas oder ist bei jemandem, den man nicht kennt und dann irgendwie, ah genau, du bist doch der
hier mit dem Podcast, ah ihr habt doch
letztens irgendwie über
Fledermäuse geredet, da habe ich ein richtig lustiges Foto,
zeige ich dir kurz.
Und dann einfach den einfach verhungern
lassen. Ich glaube, bei fremden Menschen,
was immer perfide ist, dass man von denen
geliebt werden will, weil
alle Menschen, mit denen ich befreundet bin,
ich hasse die, ich habe so wenig Gefühle für die,
ich will nicht,
mein Unterbewusstsein will nicht ansatzweise von denen geliebt werden, von denen, ich will von dieser grauen, fremden Masse Menschen geliebt werden, für die ich keinerlei Empfindungen habe. Die, von denen ich geliebt werde, und deswegen glaube ich, bei denen würde ich einfach tagelang verweilen, auf das Foto warten. Weil irgendwann fände ich es ja auch lustig mir auch so eine Challenge draus machen. Ja, du willst einfach einen guten Ruf haben. Und das glaube ich, das wäre vielleicht auch mal wieder eine Startup-Idee. Wir brauchen ja neue Ideen wieder, nachdem die letzte abgeschmettert wurde mit dem Popcorn-Versand. Ja. Und zwar sowas wie Ruf.de, wo Leute checken können, wie ihr Ruf ist. Also als was sie gelten. Du meinst wie Schufa, nur nicht finanziell. Ja genau, Schufa persönlich. So wie wir letztens gesprochen haben, Rufa, perfekt, Rufa.de. Genauso Bierernst mit diesem Stockfood-Familienbild und auch so ein ganz typisches, weil Schufa ist ja das deutscheste Logo, was man sich auch nur vorstellen kann. Und das Ruf war genau so, so ganz stockernstes Logo. So diese Stock-Footage-Familie, aber man sieht im Flur, wie zwei Leute so tuscheln und sich unterhalten über die Familie. Und da kann man anfragen, wie sein Ruf steht. Und dann ist da natürlich die Frage, dann werden deine Freunde interviewt und gefragt, anonym. Und dann kriegst du so eine Ruferbestätigung, ja, sie gelten als besonders unzuverlässig, aber als besonders grosszügig. Und dann werden einfach die Attribute aufgedrückt, so nach Prozenten. Ich glaube, das wäre ein Riesenerfolg, weil jeder will wissen, wie man gilt, wie der Ruf ist. Finde ich total super. Ich glaube, das ist eine gute Idee. Aber Rufer kostet auch ein bisschen. Also wenn man da für jede Anforderung des eigenen Rufs muss man 99,99 Euro zahlen und so, aber dann kriegst du auch eine Auswertung, die aussagekräftig ist. Aber wie läuft das dann? Also man kann natürlich mit Big Data arbeiten und so und sich bei Facebook anzapfen. Small Data. Oder halt Medium Data. Oder du schickst halt eine Mail raus an alle Freunde, die sagen, beschreiben sie anonym diese Personen und der Algorithmus baut dann daraus so eine Einschätzung. So eine super vorgefertigte mathematische Auswertung, wo am Ende nur in Rot, Orange, Grün oder Gelb quasi der Score steht. Ja, man kriegt das ja nur manchmal so über Ecken wieder gesagt, so übrigens der Typ, der meinte, du bist total so und so und mich überrascht das immer total. Ich denke mir so, was, wie kommt das denn zustande? Also man hat seine Wirkung ja oft nicht unter Kontrolle auf andere Menschen. Und da mal wirklich reinzutauschen. Dabei hat man seine Wirkung auf andere Menschen ziemlich doll unter Kontrolle. Ja, du kannst natürlich, du hast ein Bild, wie du wirken willst, aber wie du tatsächlich ankommst, ist dann die Frage. Ja, stimmt. Also finde ich super, wenn man einfach eine, ich würde jetzt aber nicht so sehr ins Detail gehen, in der Auswertung dann, sondern eher quasi so drei Schlagwörter, sie gelten als hm, hm und hm und ihr Gesamtscore ist dann einfach von 0% maximal unbeliebt bis 100% maximal beliebt, hast du dann quasi, kriegst du dann eine prozentuale Auswertung. Und dann so unterschrieben vom steilig geprüften R-Doktor. Ja, finde ich richtig gut. Finde ich super. Rufa, halte die Augen offen. Ich überlege nur, ob man da Daten hinverkaufen kann, sozusagen, dass man Geld kriegt. Also so bewährt, also du sagst, du willst dich als Bewerten sie ihre Nachbarn. Genau, du willst dich als Rufa-Profiler bewerben und dann kriegst du so Formulare für hundert Leute in deiner Umgebung, die musst du alle profilen und für jeden kriegst du eine. Genau, das machen wir im Pyramidensystem. Ja, genau. Ganz klassisch, dass man dann quasi. Kann man dann weiterreichen. Man kann es weiterreiten, der andere und du kriegst dann seine Provision. Du profitierst von den Leuten, denen du wiederum die Zettel gibst. Ja, das finde ich eine gute Idee. Also im Pyramidensystem machen wir auch ganz offen. Ja, ja. Wenn man es vorher hat. Nö, Pyramide ist ja keine schlechte Form. Ich finde es nicht die schlechteste Form. Es ist überhaupt keine schlechte Form.
Es ist rein geometrisch gesprochen.
Absolut, ja.
Nicht moralisch.
Es ist ein Kreis.
Du willst kein Kreissystem haben.
Wir sprechen, wie gesagt, nicht von Moral.
Wir sprechen rein von der Geometrie.
Absolut, das ist das Wichtigste.
Ich finde, das ist keine schlechte Form.
Ja.
So, und dann, wenn man das, glaube ich, transparent auch sagt, ist man auch fein raus.
Ja, klar.
Also wir sind ein Pyramidensystem, das ist aber ganz klar.
Aber wir sind kein Schneeballsystem. Okay. Außer im Winter. Also das muss ganz klar sein, aber das ist für mich eine gute Idee. Es gibt keine Schneeballsysteme mehr. Es dauert nicht mehr lange, es gibt gar keine Schneeballsysteme. Es sind Eissysteme, äh Wassersysteme. Die Kinder wissen nicht mehr, was Schneeball überhaupt sind. Die Kinder wissen nicht mehr, was Schneeballsysteme sind. Traurig. Ja, oder was Lawinen sind. Dann sagst du, boah, da kam eine richtige Lawine an Kommentare. Ne was? Kommentare. Was wenn Schnee... Ach Gott. Na ja, gibt es Schlammlawinen, ne? Ja, aber wie oft gibt es Schlammlawinen, Stefan? Ich glaube immer mehr. Schlawinen. Wie oft gibt es das? Ja gut, es gibt natürlich noch Geröll und Schudlawinen. Mir gefällt das sehr gut. Wir arbeiten mal dran. Könnt ihr mal in unserem neuen Reddit ausprobieren? Vielleicht machen wir da einen Ruferbeitrag, einen Thread auf und ihr könnt dann da vielleicht mal so ein paar Photoshop-Entwürfe oder so machen für unsere Website, die Rufer und ja, vielleicht könnt ihr auch schon mal ein Formular vorbereiten. Und ja, vielleicht können wir auch für euch mal dann ein Ruferformular ausfüllen. Vielen Dank an einen unserer Hörer, der hat mal ausgerechnet, wie unsere Snack-Versand-Idee funktionieren könnte. Er hat tatsächlich ein komplettes Spreadsheet gemacht. Aber wir haben ein Spreadsheet bekommen. Wir haben eine Worst Case. Wir haben ein Spreadsheet bekommen, wie das funktionieren kann. Wir haben nämlich die Idee gehabt, Popcorn versandt. Und er rechnet hier erstmal alles aus, was es braucht, was man alles bestellen muss, wie viel man haben muss. Also, ich hätte nicht vergessen, was unsere Idee war. War das jetzt die finale Idee, auf die wir uns gar nicht haben, dass man zum Film quasi macht Netflix an.
Gibt's ein Kinosnack.org?
Kinosnack.org, wo du Sachen dir liefern lassen kannst, Popcornnachos. So, er rechnet die erstmal aus. Wir haben Miete für 500 Euro im Monat, Einrichtung für 20.000 Euro, Müllcontainer für 1.250 Euro und die Popcornmaschine für 15.000 Euro. Aber Miete von 100 Quadratmetern 500 Euro. Ja, das hatte ich auch gedacht, ein bisschen wenig, oder?
Ja, also dann sind wir schon mal in Köln.
Also dann sind wir vielleicht irgendwo auf dem Land oder sowas,
aber und dann brauchen wir auch ein bisschen länger.
Dann haben wir vier Lieferwerken.
Acht Stunden dauert die Lieferung.
Mit 1.000 Euro Leasing pro Monat,
also für 1.000 Euro im Monat kriegt man
vier Lieferwerken, Spritkosten für
1.280 Euro im Monat,
dann haben wir Angestellte,
vier Fahrer, zwei Lagerarbeiter, jemanden für Bestellungen, vier Fahrer, Chef, das kostet,
also die Angestellten kosten 15.000 Euro im Monat zusammen.
Nee, aber daran müssen wir schon sparen jetzt, also die kriegen doch nicht weniger.
Werbung für 700 Euro im Monat und rechtlicher Stuff für 3000 im Monat, das heißt, wir
haben...
Generell, wenn ihr seriös drüber kommen wollt, in Excel-Tabellen, vermeidet das Wort
Stuff. Ja, und versucht Chef nicht mit drei
F zu schreiben. Das kommt aus dem Problem.
Gesamtkosten pro Monat verlaufen
damit auf
21.480
und die sofort anfallenden Kosten
sind 35.000 Euro. Gut, dann lassen wir es.
Also das ist schon mal eine ganze Menge. Aber mir gefällt Süßigkeiten
genau nach links, hat er sich geeinigt auf Treats, Gummibärchen Stuff, Skittles, Schokolade, Snickers, Bounty, Oreo, Twix und Eis. Also ich glaube, ich finde es interessant, weil das scheint ja wirklich so eine BWL-mässige Berechnung zu sein. Finde ich toll. Wäre das? Muss ich gleich nochmal schauen. Ja. Und dann, wie viel kostet die Produktion von einer Tonne Popcorn?
Und zwar, eine Tonne Mais kostet 140 Euro.
Ja, also.
Eine Tonne Mais, 140 Euro.
Eine Tonne Zucker kostet 480 Euro.
Und Öl kostet 190 Euro.
Naja, 1,2 Tonnen Zucker kosten 480 Euro.
Ah, ja.
Er hat schon sogar, Moment, für Popcorn besteht so fast 1 zu 1,2 Teilen aus Mais und Zucker. Und Ölnummer 0,16 Teil. Das heißt, du brauchst für eine Tonne Popcorn 800 Euro. 800 Euro für eine Tonne. Das heißt, für eine grosse Popcorn zahlst du 21 Cent, für eine mittlere Popcorn 14 Cent und für eine kleine Popcorn 12 Cent. Für süss, ne? Also Popcorn ist unfassbar billig in der Herstellung, also lächerlich billig. Ja, das ist lächerlich billig, aber das Spannende ist, dass er das auch nochmal für salzig ausgerechnet hat. Und salzig ist viel billiger. Ja, weil er zuckerteuer ist. Aber dass man ein Popcorn ein zu eins teilen, gewichtsmässig aus Mais und Zucker besteht, wusste ich nicht. Wusste ich auch nicht, aber anscheinend scheint das zu sein. Also das ist schon enorm. Aus einer Tonne Mais können 3000 grosse Popcorn-Tüten oder 5000 mittlere Popcorn-Tüten. So, und das ist jetzt natürlich die Frage, wie viel Geld kriegen wir. Und da machen wir eine Beispielrechnung für den Raum Stuttgart. Belieferung von
40 Kilometer Radius max, circa
eine Million Menschen, circa 60
Prozent haben Netflix und Co.
50 Prozent sind potenzielle
Kunden.
Das ist schon mal gut. Davon essen
circa 40 Prozent, also
120.000 gerne Popcorn zum
Filmen. Ich weiß nicht, wo die Zahlen herkommen.
Nee, wenn die in Stuttgart waren, haben die wahrscheinlich auch an der Umfrage teilgenommen. 35% davon denken gar nicht daran, es zu bestellen. Gut, aber dann kann man eine Werbung. Denken gar nicht dran. Unsere Marktforschung hat ergeben, dass unsere Kunden gar nicht dran denken, unseren Service zu benutzen. Ich finde es nur missverständlich formuliert, weil es ist so ein Ich denke gar nicht dran. Oder es ist so ein Die wissen es einfach nicht. Auf der anderen Seite finde ich es aber gut, weil da kann man ja an den Werbekosten erarbeiten, dass man vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Leute dazu bekommt, über Treiber nachzudenken. Ja, also das ist der erste Schritt. Träume nicht mal davon. Wir würden nicht mal im Traum daran denken, was zu bestellen. Das heißt, wir haben am Schluss 78.000 potenzielle Kunden und von diesen 78.000 bestellt jeder einmal in drei Monaten.
Das heißt, wir haben pro Monat 26.000.
Ist das spekulativ oder beruht das irgendwie?
Und funktioniert die Welt so wie dieser Zettel, dieser Excel-Sheet?
Ja, du machst einfach, wie viele Leute gibt es und dann machst du Prozente und hoffst, dass es einigermaßen stimmt.
Also wir haben im Raum Stuttgart 26.000 potenzielle Kunden oder tatsächliche Kunden im Monat.
So, und Hauptumersatz machen wir Donnerstag, Freitag und Samstag. Das ist lächerlich genau, dieser Spreadsheet. Also das stimmt natürlich, vielleicht machen wir einfach nur dann auf auch.
Ja, Popcorn gross verkaufen für 5,90 Euro, Mittel für 4,20 Euro und Klein für 3,50 Euro. Und das heisst, er rechnet dann aus, wie viel wir hier alles gewinnen., das heißt, insgesamt haben wir einen Gewinn pro Tag von 3.600 Euro. Täglicher Gewinn 3.600 Euro. Soll ich Steuern abziehen? Das heißt, im Monat haben wir 57.000 und nach Steuern und allem haben wir endgültigen Gewinn von 25.000 Euro im Monat. Es ist genauer, 25.000, das macht es auch lustig, 868 Euro im Monat. Das ist verdammt viel. Weiß ich nicht. 25.000 Euro im Monat. Gewinn. Also die haben ja alle Kosten schon bezahlt. Wollen wir das einfach mal unkommentiert und auch unbenannt. Diese Excel-Tabelle unbenannt, heißt nach wie vor Excel-Tabelle 1.exel, schicken wir an Netflix und sagen, könnt ihr machen. Könnt ihr machen. Wir können uns abkaufen, macht dann 30.000 Euro im Monat. Das Ganze kommt von Philipp. Vielen, vielen Dank an Philipp für diese ganze Zusammenrechnung. Ich weiß nicht, ob du irgendwas mit BWL oder sowas in der Richtung machst, aber das ist schon sehr beeindruckend. Also das alles zu sehen, was da alles anfällt an Kosten. 25.000
Euro im Monat könnten wir
verdienen, wenn wir
sagen, ja, wir gehen jetzt all in und
wir müssen halt einmal Startkapital
einsammeln, weil wir
brauchen nämlich die sofort anfallenden
Kosten von 35.000 Euro.
Also wir müssen 35.000 Euro
Kredit nehmen oder in die Hand nehmen und
dann machen wir richtig
Cash. Das heißt, wir haben das nach ein paar Monaten schon wieder
drin. Wir haben mal eine Idee.
Aber das Problem ist, wir leben halt nicht in Stuttgart.
Das heißt,
ich weiß nicht, können diese Zahlen ganz anders aussehen.
Können wir da einfach ein paar Telefonate machen,
um das Ganze in Stuttgart
einfach aus der Peripherie aufzubauen?
Ich weiß es nicht. Genau, also ich
fände es schon super, das mal zu machen, weil
einfach, um auch mal wieder eine Storyline
Vielen Dank. um das Ganze in Stuttgart einfach aus der Peripherie aufzubauen? Ich weiß es nicht. Genau, also ich fände es schon super, das mal zu machen, weil einfach um auch mal wieder eine Storyline hier zu haben, die sich mal über mehrere Folgen erstreckt, fände ich jetzt eigentlich ganz schön, das mal zu machen. Also einfach mal durchziehen. Und dann auch, ich meine, wenn wir scheitern und so, dann ist es ja auch gut für alle Leute zu merken, woran sind wir gescheitert und so. Und ihr seid alle Teil des Teams, ihr seid alle Crew. Und ich will halt so ein neues, was ich ja mag, das war ja damals schon bei den Aquarium so, als ich mein Aquarium hatte, ich wollte das gerne einrichten. Dann kamen die Fische und dann kamen die Algen und dann war es scheiße. Und ich will die ganze Arbeit nicht, ich will nur die Website designen, ich will das Logo designen, ich will diesen Shirt haben, wohin drauf Stuff draufsteht und vorne dieser Popcorn-Versand, unser Logo, das will ich, ich will die Visitenkarten und dann will ich das Büro, ich will den Schreibtisch, machen Sie bitte die Tür zu, sowas willst du sagen? Genau, ich will den, ich lasse das wirklich alles haben, ich möchte aber nicht arbeiten. Ja.
Und dann möchte ich das abstossen.
Ja.
Aber wenn wir das quasi früh genug an Netflix verkauft bekommen, was ja nicht, wäre im Prinzip auch Back to the Roots für Netflix, sind gestattet als DVD-Versand, sind jetzt Streamer und werden jetzt zu einem Popcorn-Versand, ist eigentlich der geschlossene Kreis. Ja, total. Ich meine, du musst dann natürlich wissen, wo die Leute sind, wenn sie Netflix schauen, weil dann kannst du dir nicht ein Angebot machen, dem du nicht nachkommen kannst, wenn die nicht gerade in Stuttgart leben. Ich mache dir ein Angebot, dem du nicht nachkommen kannst. Wenn die auf dem Land leben und da halt kein Fahrer hinfahren will. Also es ist schwierig auf jeden Fall, aber da überlege ich mir, gibt es nicht eine Möglichkeit, Sachen zu spielen? Planspielen. Also so eine Art Lab, aber halt für,
du bist CEO von einem gut laufenden Unternehmen.
Viel braucht man nicht. Du brauchst
einfach so fünf Mitarbeiter, fünf Schauspieler
und du sitzt in einem Büro irgendwo
in Frankfurt. Ja, lass doch mal ein altes Bürogebäude.
Nächste Idee direkt, Philipp kann es gleich wieder ein neues
Specialty aufmachen. Ja, mach mal auf. Und zwar,
und dann will ich mal sehen, wie viele Leute sich das im Traum
vorstellen können. Wir mieten nämlich
ein großes Bürogebäude, ein leerstehendes Bürogebäude,
so ein großes. Ja.
Und dann quasi müssen wir
Aber wenn ich mal sehe, wie viele Leute sich das im Traum vorstellen können. Wir mieten nämlich ein großes Bürogebäude, ein leerstehendes Bürogebäude, so ein großes. Und dann quasi müssen wir aber nur die Etagen besetzen mit Schauspielern, die wichtig sind. Die Chefetagen, ja. Und du kannst das M-, S- oder XL-Paket bestellen. XL-Paket ist, du bist wirklich Chef so einer Versicherung. Und dann sind alle Etagen voll mit Schauspielern. Und du hast auch viel zu tun. Aber dann kannst du auch wirklich, dann kannst du mit Mitarbeitern nämlich drei Ansagen, also Ansagen machen. Also du kannst Leute zurechtweisen und so und kannst Meetings einberufen und so und hast so drei Schimpftiraden frei. Und das ist einfach wie so ein Wochenende, kannst du mieten, wo du dann der Chef bist von diesem mittelständischen Unternehmen.
Es gibt ja total viele Spiele, die diese Manager machen, wo du eine Pizzeria managt oder wo du
einen Vergnügungspark managt.
Und das kann ja im Hintergrund laufen,
nur die ganzen Entscheidungen werden
halt über Mitarbeiter an den Chef herangetragen.
So, oh, Entschuldigung, wir haben jetzt hier einen Vorfall
in Sektor 3, da ist jetzt der
Löwe ausgebrochen, was sollen wir machen?
Und du entscheidest und dann... Kornspeicher ist voll, mein Lord. Genau, so was. Und dann der Mitarbeiter, der Schauspieler Tipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptipptas gut funktioniert, weil es gibt ja auch genug Leute, die sich so ein Lamborghini mieten, um damit ein Foto zu machen und dann irgendwie in so einem Büro mit Mitarbeitern irgendwie Meeting oder sowas und alle sehen da und hören dir zu. Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das funktioniert. Ja, finde ich ganz toll. Einfach mal, auch da kann man sich direkt wieder eine Website mieten. Das Podcast-Ufo heißt nämlich auch dieses Angebot. Da kann man dann wirklich, glaube die ist schon weg, kann man hingehen und das finde ich super, weil das will doch jeder. Jeder will doch nur die Macht kurz ausleben.
Jeder will nicht wirklich die Verantwortung tragen. Und dann kann man ja auch zusammenarbeiten mit Fabrikbesichtigungen. Dann fragst du halt mal nach, guten Tag, Will hier von Make Your Dream Come True, Make Your Boring Dream Come True, könnten wir mal bitte ihre Abfüllanlage besichtigen? Wir haben da jemanden, der dafür bezahlt, dass wir so tun, als sei der der Chef. Wenn sie mitspielen, kriegen sie 1000 Euro und wir kommen einfach vorbei und lassen uns die Firma erklären, die Fabrik erklären. Und dann kommt er mit so einem schwarzen BMW davor gefahren und dann kommt er da rein und wird alles erklärt. Ist das prinzipiell so eine Mietwagenfirma, nur dass du halt deinen Tag als Chef mietest. Ja genau, deinen Tag als Chef. Ja, finde ich super, so ein Planspiel. Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn ihr zum Beispiel vor einer großen beruflichen Entscheidung steht, wie zum Beispiel, euch wurde eine Beförderung angeboten, ihr wisst nicht, wollt ihr das zeitlich überhaupt hinkriegen, wie soll es noch in den nächsten fünf Jahren aussehen, du wolltest es noch ein bisschen lockerer machen, keine Ahnung, traust du so viel Verantwortung zu, könnt ihr das ja als Planspiel nutzen. Wie seid ihr im Job? Wie seid ihr überhaupt als Chef? Vor allem, wir sparen ja Geld, indem auch die Angestellten nicht alle Schauspieler sind, sondern auch Teilnehmer. Das heißt natürlich, die... Seid ihr Chef oder Chefin und wollt mal Mitarbeiterin sein, dann könnt ihr euch mal da einschleusen. Genau, und so was, aber so Upper Management, die halt schon was zu sagen haben und nicht ganz oben sind, die können ja auch wiederum... So, aber jetzt ist Switch the Roo GmbH. Switch the Roo Inc. Ihr seid Detektiv und wollt mal Verbrecher sein, oder ihr seid Verbrecher und wollt mal Detektiv sein, wir machen euren Traum wahr. Ja. Oder auch so eine Mordermittlung oder sowas, ist auch bestimmt auch interessant. Ich glaube, wir nähern uns einfach immer näher einem Escape Room. Einfach so, ich weiß nicht, war noch nie im Escape Room, ich kann mir noch nichts vorstellen, aber ist es nicht auch so, dass es dann so aussieht wie so eine Detektei und dann kommen Leute rein und sagen, wir haben diese Indizien und die und die und dann muss man eine Entscheidung treffen? Ich weiß, du kannst es dir wahrscheinlich nicht vorstellen, aber ich war noch nie in einem Escape Room. Wahnsinn, du warst so wirklich schon überall. Du warst doch schon mit dem holländischen Botschafter Lasertag spielen und jetzt sagst du, du warst noch nie in einem Escape Room? Ja, war ich noch nie drin. Ich bin großer Freizeitpark-Fan und ich glaube, ich wäre auch großer Fan von guten Escape-Rooms. Aber ich bin ein bisschen abgeschreckt von sehr schlechten Escape-Rooms. Nils Buckel wäre keinem gesagt. Wo man zu leicht rauskommt. Ich soll unbedingt in meine Escape-Room gehen, das wäre genau mein Ding. Übrigens auch so ein Ding, was ich gerne bei Rufa checken würde. Ja, was ist genau mein Ding? Und warum denken alle, Escape-Rooms sind mein Ding und muss ich dann meine Persönlichkeit ändern? Ja, das stimmt. Das wäre dann natürlich der nächste Punkt von Rufa, ist dann Rufa Plus, wo du dann auch noch an deinem Ruf arbeiten kannst. Also wo einerseits natürlich so ein Persönlichkeitscoaching im Vordergrund steht, aber auch, dass die Leute manipuliert werden, anders von dir zu denken. Also wo du dann sozusagen einen Ausblick haben kannst, ich hätte gerne drei Prozent mehr Beliebtheit, machen wir, kostet 30.000 Euro. Ich finde es sehr gut, dass ähnlich bei der richtigen Schufa es super schwer ist, den Rufa-Score zu ändern. Ja, das ist super schwer. Wenn du einmal runtergerankt wurdest, ist es fast unmöglich. Also es kommt einem sozialen Tod gleich. Du kannst, es ist super schwierig wieder aufzusteigen auf der Ruferliste und den Ruferscore zu verbessern.
Ja, das stimmt. So stehst du so,
so in der Medien, in der sehr kleinen,
überschaubaren Medienbubble in Deutschland.
Was war dein Ruferscore? Das Einzige, was ich mal
gehört habe von jemandem, der mit mir zusammengearbeitet hat,
da haben wir irgendwann mal später noch
für so ein Projekt und dann haben wir ein Jahr später noch mal
mit dem, über den gesprochen und dann meinte,
ja, der meinte ja, der hat mit mir gesprochen
und der meinte, also der Florentin,
der ist echt ziemlich autistisch, oder?
Wo ich
erst mal dachte, okay,
was genau heißt das jetzt?
Weil es ist ja nicht direkt negativ,
also finde ich zumindest, es ist nicht direkt negativ gemeint.
Nee. Es ist auf eine Art
das ist so eine Aussage, wo man nachfragen will, was genau meinst du damit? Also was ist, aber ich fühle mich jetzt erstmal nicht beleidigt, aber mich würde schon interessieren, was damit genau gemeint ist. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber das ist so ein Punkt, vor allem ich glaube, das ist der eigentliche Punkt, der an Rufer interessant ist. Du kannst dann vielleicht eine anonyme Anfrage stellen an die Person, der sagt, ja, der ist unhöflich. Und du denkst immer, ich denke, ich bin eigentlich höflich. Und dann kannst du nämlich für Schufa Premium, äh, Rufer Premium, kannst du nämlich eine anonyme Mail schicken an die Person, die das gesagt hat, du bist unhöflich und fragen, ja, wie meinst du das? Was ist dein scheiß Problem? Genau, dann kann die Person antworten, du dummes Schwein. Ja, ja. Keine schlechte Idee. Ich finde das super. Ich finde Rufer toll, ich finde unser Planspiel toll. Warum sind wir nicht reich eigentlich, verdammt, nochmal? Aber daran könnt ihr was ändern. Der Ufo-Club für euch. Der Ufo-Club ist nämlich gestartet. Vielen Dank an alle, die uns bis dahin schon supporten haben. Ja, ey, wir haben so viel Spaß im Clubhaus. Wir haben Baumhaus, irgendjemand macht immer Bohle, ganz interessanter Effekt. Alkoholfreie Bohle? Irgendjemand macht immer Bohle, es ist immer eine Bohle da. Und Punsch. Nie zwei, aber auch nie null, es ist immer eine Bohle und manchmal Punsch dabei. Also, falls ihr auch Bock habt, im Clubhaus mit uns Spaß zu haben. Genau, da könnt ihr uns absolut unterstützen auf Patreon.com. Ihr habt gemerkt, es ist einiges anders geworden. Wir haben jetzt auch ein Reddit, habe ich gerade schon ein bisschen angeteaset, das Podcast-Ufo. Da geht ja einiges schon vor sich. Und es wird aber auch Merch geben, der dauerhaft verfügbar ist. Wir arbeiten an T-Shirts, die immer verfügbar sind. Und da könnt ihr dann auch, falls ihr Zeit habt, immer mal gerne reinschauen. Aber im Reddit, da tut sich schon einiges. Wir kriegen wahnsinnig viele Elfchen, also es ist wirklich unglaublich. Aber so, dass man auch langsam sagen müsste, es reicht. Ja, es reicht, lass uns mal zum Zwölfchen gehen. Einfach irgendwie jetzt muss es in der nächste Schritt gehen. Aber es freut mich, weil wir die Leute auch zum Dichten bringen. Und das ist mir ganz besonders wichtig, denn ich liebe die Lyrik und ich möchte, dass mehr Leute dichten. Ich finde nur ganz ehrlich, kurze Kritik am Elfchen, es ist ein bisschen einfach. Also erst ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube, wir alle benutzen den Elfchen auch noch falsch und ich möchte dem Elfchen nicht unrecht tun. Aber es wirkt ein bisschen wie so ein Shortcut, weil es wirkt sofort, allein wenn man einen Absatz reinhaut, wirkt es gedichtet. Im Endeffekt ist es einfach einen Satz, die meisten Schreien machen einen Satz und am Ende ein lustiges Wort. Es ist halt besonders beliebt, wenn man nicht reimen muss. Ich glaube, das ist der große Vorteil am Elfchen, was viele Leute von Gedichten abhält, ist das Reimen. Genau, ich glaube nur, und das ist ja nicht schlimm, dass man nicht reimen muss. Es wirkt nur wie ein Satz, wo ihr einfach ein paar Mal auf Enter drückt. Und das wollen wir nicht. Also wir wollen schon, wenn Elfchen, dann auch wieder mit künstlerischem Anspruch. Hat Goethe ein Elfchen geschrieben? Ich glaube, er hätte sich im Grabe umgedreht, noch zu Lebzeiten. Goethe, Rilke, wir müssen mal gucken, ob es irgendwie so einen Hölderlin Elfin gibt, irgendwie von einem berühmten Dichter, dass man wirklich mal auch einen Standard hat und einfach sagt, so das ist jetzt hier der Standard. Weil ich glaube nämlich, du hast eine Zeile und die zweite führt das nicht einfach fort, diesen Satz, sondern nimmt sich Bezug auf diese Seite, bringt aber ein anderes Gefühl mit. Also denkt ein bisschen filmischer, denkt vielleicht eher an eine andere Szene, nicht an den Fortlauf der gleichen Szene. Also versucht mal ein bisschen, wir müssen wieder über künstlerischen Anspruch reinbekommen, das Gefühl, beim Elfchen. Es gibt einige tolle, tolle, tolle, tolle Sachen im Reddit. Schaut mal vorbei, reddit.com slash r slash das Podcast. Ufo, könnt ihr gerne vorbeikommen und alles diskutieren. Da werden jetzt auch die Kommentare zu den Folgen stattfinden, da unsere Website keine Kommentarfunktion
mehr hat, könnt ihr da die Folgen gerne
kommentieren und wir treiben uns da auch rum.
Stefan auch, Stefan in den Reddit.
Ich war schon häufig im Reddit,
liebe Reddit, aber ich
bin jetzt zum ersten Mal Moderator
und schreibe jetzt auch zum ersten Mal,
würde ich jetzt auch mal ab und zu sagen. Normalerweise bin ich
immer nur ein stiller Leser bei Reddit, aber jetzt
durch meine Moderatorenfunktion werde ich knallhart einfach für Recht und Ordnung sorgen. Man hat zu viel Macht. Ich merke das ja auch so bei meinem Stream oder so, wenn man einfach die Macht hat, Leute zu sperren. Es ist zu viel Macht für einen Menschen, weil natürlich wird man mit Meinungen konfrontiert, die man nicht lesen will oder mit Verhalten, das man nicht gut findet. Und dann einfach auf einen Knopf drücken zu können und zu sagen, ich will nicht
einen Kommentar lesen,
der nicht
hundertprozentig mit meiner Meinung übereinstimmt,
fliegt der raus.
Es ist ja wirklich, du hast ja die
Macht. Wurde schon mal ein Podcast
Host
von seinem eigenen Reddit gesperrt,
weil er nervig,
so nervig.
Bei Rocky Beans passiert das alles.
Aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Weil ich bin, weil vielleicht ehrlich gesagt, ich fände es lustig.
Nee, ich bin natürlich ganz.
Die einzigen, die gebannt sind, bei uns, wir beide.
Die Red List.
Und dann kommt es einfach nur B-Reddit auf. Ja, genau, machen wir beide die Red List. Und dann kommt es einfach nur wir beide. Und dann macht es nur wir beide. Und dann macht es nur wir beide auf. Ja, genau. Wir haben unser eigenes Reddit. Nein, schaut da mal vorbei. Coole Sachen auf jeden Fall. Bilder sind auch erlaubt. Genau, denn wir haben ja auch ein neues Logo. Christopher Niemann, einer der bekanntesten Illustratoren der Welt, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, hat uns nämlich das neue UFO designt. Verrückterweise, wir haben
da einfach mal auf doof eine E-Mail hingeschrieben und
er hatte Bock und er hatte auch schon
unser Cover für die Tour
gemacht und jetzt unser UFO
und das Beste daran ist, ihr könnt es
selber mitgestalten. Wir haben auch schon ganz tolle Entwürfe
bekommen. Supergeile Entwürfe, richtig gut. Ihr könnt nämlich
quasi in der Original
Podcast Covergrösse
euch das, unsere Website
podcast-ufo.fail, könnt euch das runterladen,
wenn ihr runterscrollt zum Cover.
Und das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. quasi in der Original-Podcast-Cover-Grösse. Euch das, unsere Website, podcast-upe.fail, könnt ihr euch das runterladen, wenn ihr runterscrollt zum Cover. Und könnt es verändern, wie ihr wollt. Wie ihr Bock habt, wir freuen uns über alles. Ziel ist natürlich, langfristig sehr viele vergleichbare Cover zu haben, um natürlich das auf den Social-Media-Plattformen rauszuhauen, aber auch mal vielleicht als Cover zu benutzen für unseren Podcast. Vielleicht aber auch für Merch, wenn wir das dürfen und mit euch da gesprochen haben, kriegen wir neues, cooles Merch mit euren Motiven. Oder vielleicht, keine Ahnung, bringen wir das mal als Prinz raus. Und ihr habt sehr viele vergleichbare so Andy-Warhol-mäßig Ufos, die an die Wand ballern können. Also da ist sehr viel Potenzial. Wir freuen uns sehr, was das neue Ufo macht. Ja, tut euch da aus und schickt uns die. Auf jeden Fall, wir haben schon sehr, sehr coole Sachen bekommen, freuen wir uns immer drüber. Ja, auf jeden Fall, finde ich super. Ja, ich habe, weil ich mich ja in den letzten Wochen vielen Freizeitparks rumgetrieben habe, ist es wieder der Fall. Ich war jetzt für ein paar Tage über in Paris, in der schönen Stadt Paris. Und ja, dann war ich auch da. Natürlich habe ich mich nicht lumpen lassen, hat das Disneyland nicht genommen. Du warst da. Das Problem ist nur, sagen wir so, ich bin morgens hin und ich bin ja auch so ein Typ, wenn man in den Freizeitpark geht, ich stehe um Punkt der Uhrzeit auf der Matte, wo der Freizeitpark aufmacht, weil man bezahlt dann ja für den Tag und scheiß, keine Minute wird verstrichen bei mir. Also die mit mir in den Freizeitpark gehen haben keinen Spaß, weil man muss
sehr früh aufstehen, im Punkt 39
da zu sein. Disneyland macht um 39 auf.
Du warst wahrscheinlich mit lauter Deutschen da in der
ersten Reihe, einfach schön während
den Park aufmacht. So, Problem war nur,
leider habe ich mir
einen Tag vorher
so ein bisschen so ein Norovirus eingefangen
und ich habe, also ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben so ein furchtbares Malenproblem gehabt. Das ist verrückt, weil ich erinnere mich, ich war auch im Disneyland und ich hatte auch Durchfall den ganzen Tag. Oder ich hatte zumindest Durchfall den ganzen Tag. Ich hatte so schlimmen Durchfall. Ich weiss nicht, was das ist. Aufregung? Das kann sein. Nee, ich hatte wirklich einfach, ich hatte was gegessen, ein Kumpel, mit dem ich in Paris war, der macht das auch kurz vorher, also uns hat Paris kurz einfach fertig gemacht, die ersten Tage waren schön, aber irgendwann hat die dreckige Stadt dann einen noch ein bisschen krank gemacht.
Ähm, jedenfalls, also ich hatte unglaublich, war richtig schlecht auch morgens und ich war, stand so ein bisschen neben mir, also ich war wie so ein Schleier, war auf mir gelegt und wie man das so kennt, wenn man krank ist, neben sich ein bisschen schwindelig war mir und hab dann die Nummer angerufen, die Hotline von Disneyland, weil ich dachte, weil die Tickets sind jetzt gerade auch wegen der Situation datiert. Das heißt, es gibt nur, du kaufst ein Ticket für den Tag, kannst dann an dem Tag hingehen. Da hab ich da angerufen und gefragt, ob ich nicht, weil ich krank geworden bin, irgendwie übermorgen oder so kommen könnte. Und dann hatte diese Frau war super nervig zu mir am Telefon, die war richtig penetrant nervig, hat gesagt, nee, das kann man nur 48 Stunden vorher klären. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ich wusste ja nicht, dass ich krank wurde. Was, Minimaus oder? Was, Minimaus, ja, es war Minimaus, goofy. Und sie war wirklich ein bisschen, ja, keine Ahnung, penetrant ist sie auf dem Punkt behangen geblieben, dass ich es hätte vorher studieren müssen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja geht er nicht, bin er krank geworden. Ja, da müssen sie Attest vorlegen. Ich würde jetzt aber nicht gerne zum Friseur, also ich will jetzt nicht zum Arzt gehen. Ich spreche diese Sprache auch nicht. Le Dokteur. Zum Dokteur, zu Saint-Excellence will ich jetzt nicht gehen unbedingt, weil es ja nur Durchfall. Ich komme aber die Runden, ich werde das Ding wuppen, ich werde überleben,
ich muss ja nicht zum Arzt, sondern meinte sie.
Ich kann ihnen ein Foto schicken, wenn sie nicht glauben.
Die meinte, wir können das nicht machen, das würden ja sonst
alle machen. Und daran
habe ich mich ein bisschen festgewissen an diesem Argument,
weil es geht ja immer noch darum,
nicht ins Disneyland zu können.
Wenn wir es so machen,
dann würde ja einfach gar niemand mehr ins Disneyland gehen, das würde ich auch nicht machen. Und dann habe ich auch gesagt, weil alle Leute lieben es, ihr datiert das Disneyland-Ticket auf übermorgen. Vor allem, was ist euer Problem denn daran, wenn alle, wenn immer alle übermorgen kommen wollen? Das Problem ist ja gerade, wenn es nicht alle machen. Wenn es alle machen, ist das kein Problem. Und dann habe ich gefragt, warum wollen das denn alle machen? Weil es geht ja darum, ich will ja ins, ihr seid das Disneyland, ich will hin. Es ist nicht so, dass ich einen Vorteil habe, nicht zu kommen. Es ist nicht wie ein Amtsbesuch oder so, wo man nicht hin will. Es ist fucking, das können ja alle zu Hause bleiben. Aber ich bin nicht ganz verstanden. Ja, Ende vom Lied war, dass diese Frau der Grund war, warum ich mich da morgens hingeschleppt habe. Und das Ding ist ja, dass der Ausserhalt von Paris ist, also man fährt da auch lange hin. Ich habe schon bei der Zugfahrt so gemerkt, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, wenn das mal nicht mal ein schlimmes Erlebnis wird. Dann natürlich nimmt Adrenalin Oberhand. Ja. Man betritt da, man geht durch die Pforte des Schlosses, überall ist Lautmusik an, die haben auch gerade A Jolly Good Christmas Time. Von daher, im ganzen Park liefen diese Figuren rum, diese Walking-Characters, alle haben getanzt, alle haben getanzt, überall. Das hat mich auch so ein bisschen angesteckt, diese gute Laune, und ich hatte sofort mal, sofort war die Krankheit die verflogen, mir ging es total gut, und ich konnte mich aufraffen, weil der Space Mountain, die bekannte Achterbahn indoors, wo du reingeschossen wirst, quasi damals der Jules Verne mässig gethemt, ist jetzt Hyper Space Mountain Star Wars. Ist es ein Star Wars Ride? Ich hätte mega Bock drauf, habe mich reingesetzt. Ja, und da fing aber quasi der Horrortritt für mich an. Erst mal rein geschmacklich, weil was was eine Scheiße, die haben sich keine Mühe gegeben, die Warteschlange war, da war einmal so ein Monitor hingeklatscht, wo einem eine Frau mit so einem Star Wars, schlechtem Star Wars Outfit sagt, wie die Bahn funktioniert, aber nicht mehr so irgendwie in Charakter, so machen sie sich bereit für ihre Mission, sondern steigen sie nicht aus der Achterbahn aus, aber halt keine Mühe gegeben, da irgendwie so ein bisschen im Thema zu bleiben. Und überall waren quasi noch diese alten Jules Verne-Wandverzierungen, aber einfach mit einem Star-Wars-Poster überklebt oder so. Mit so einem Chewbacca drauf einfach. Es war genau so, es war lächerlich. Also es war keine Mühe gegeben, es gab keine Umgestaltung. Und dann der ganze Ride an sich war einfach nur alle coolen Planeten, die dann so da drin waren, die man so umfahren hat mit der Bahn, waren jetzt große Videoscreens, einfach da vorgeknallt, wo dann so ein TIE-Fighter auf dich schießt und so. Das einzige Coole war die Star-Wars-Musik, aber also dem hat sich gar keine Mühe gegeben, es war richtig nervig und ich weiß nicht, ob es daran lag, aber dann begrennt mein Körper nicht jetzt der Fall. Und ich habe schon gemerkt, nach der ersten Achterbahn, oh Gott, das war es jetzt. Mir war so, missverteile ich das gut, mir war sehr schlecht. Ich habe mich dann noch aufgerafft zu dem Haunted House, der Haunted Mansion, dem Geisterschloss, Geisterschloss, Eddie Murphy, natürlich wollte ich da das Geisterschloss gehen und natürlich der letzte Ride, zu dem ich es noch geschafft habe, wo schon mein Magen gesagt hat, das war es hier gleich für dich, war natürlich der Pirates of the Caribbean. Na klar. Und da musst du natürlich hin. Gibt es da dieses Johnny Depp Hologramm? Ne, eine Animatronic. Ah, okay. Aber da mir noch mal das Herz auf. Das war so schön für mich, als einer der Grössten, mit dir, ja, die beiden Grössten Pirates-Fans, da durchzufahren. Und das ist wirklich ganz toll gemacht, alle singen sie Drink Up Me Hardys und du hast halt diese Tortuga-Welt und von überall singen die Piraten und das ist ganz toll gemacht.
Ja, und dann bin ich um 13 Uhr rausgegangen aus dem Park und ich weiß nicht, ob das jemandem schon mal vor euch passiert ist, aber man kann nicht so einfach, der Park sieht es nicht vor, dass man rausgeht. Ja, klar. Und dann stehen dann draußen an einem Eingang, der nur für Eingang, also es kommen aber noch Leute rein, was ich gar nicht verstehen kann, als jemand, der um 39 auf der Matte steht, wieder um 13 Uhr noch Leute kommen kann, was ist denn mit denen los? Und dann gehst du raus und dann wirst du auch gefragt, warum man geht, weil irgendwie, keine Ahnung, denken die, man hat eine Bombe deponiert und geht jetzt raus oder sowas. Man wird jedenfalls so ein bisschen interviewt, warum man da jetzt rausgehen will. Ja, habe ich es dann geschafft und dann habe ich mich einfach nur, keine Ahnung, mein Körper war ein großer Shutdown und ich bin in so einer Bahn zusammengesunken und musste dann irgendwann raus und habe dann tatsächlich einfach, es ging nicht anders, weil es war gar kein Klo auf der Bahn und ich habe es dann auch nicht mehr zum Klo geschafft und habe einfach in den Pariser Urban Station kotzen müssen.
In den Mülleimer.
Da sind die ganze Zuckerwatte und Popcorn aus dem Disneyland.
Alle Pommes, die grossen
Lollis, alles
und dann, das war mein Disneyland-Tag.
Also grauenhaft, mir ging es so schlecht
und dann war ich da in
Garde-Lion. Aber wie lief das genau
ab dieses Erbrechen? Also ich bin
in der Bahn gesessen, habe dann noch gedacht,
ja, ich kann nicht, ich muss hier raus, ich muss hier raus.
Bahn hielt an, quasi so erste
Station, wo man dann wieder Paris erreicht hat.
Der Rest der Bahnfahrt
war ich einfach nur in mich zusammengesunken und Augen
zu und fast weggeschlafen,
weil mein Körper gesagt hat, ich hätte auch Schüttelfrost
plötzlich bekommen. Alles nur wegen dieser
Frau, die gesagt hat, nein, sonst würden ja alle
später kommen. Und
dann habe ich gemerkt, wie man
Vielen Dank. weil mein Körper gesagt hat, ich hätte auch Schüttelfrost plötzlich bekommen. Alles nur wegen dieser Frau, die gesagt hat, nein, sonst würden ja alle später kommen. Und dann habe ich gemerkt, wie man das hat, wenn man einem übel wird und dann läuft schon so der Mund nass und sowas und die Augen werden nass. Und dann bin ich einfach bei der ersten Testung rausgerannt und dann war eine sehr schöne, saubere Station, wo halt überall quasi Mülleimer auch gerade erst neu gemacht wurden, also mit neuen Beuteln drin und so. Und bin dann zum Mülleimer. Und es war eine sehr volle Station. Also es war unangenehm hochtausend. Gerade für jemanden wie mich, Ruf slash Rufa.de, ja einfach der ja auch geliebt werden will von allen Fremden. und dann von meinen Lieblingsmenschen, den Fremden, so zu versagen, körperlich zu zerfallen. ja, rückblickend habe ich gemerkt, in dem Moment, dass der Kumpel, der dabei war, hat mir nicht den Rücken gestreichelt. Oh, was? Wo ich dann dachte, in dem Moment ... Das ist Verrat. Einsteigendes Erlebnis eigentlich, in der Freundschaft auch. Da merkt man, wer ein wirklicher Freund ist. Nee, aber er hat gesagt, er würde es nicht wollen. Das war danach ein Thema. Du übergibst dich und danach direkt die Diskussion. Danach mit den Tränen in diesen Augen, den roten Augen noch. Warum hast du mir gerade nicht den Rücken gestreichelt? Gab es noch eine Diskussion, er hätte selber nicht gewollt, weil es natürlich auch ein bisschen ... Es ist doof gesagt. Ich verstehe ihn aber auch. Es macht ihn noch schwächer in dem Moment ein bisschen. Aber was genau meinst du mit Rücken streicheln? Einfach streicheln? Dieses kumpelige Ich-bin-bei-dir. Weil was ich erkenne, ist, dass man die Haare halten, wenn jemand lange Haare hat. Das habe ich ja kurze Haare. Das ist klar. Aber dann auch noch streicheln? Nee, aber was ich schon eher machen würde, ich würde demjenigen, wenn ich mit dir jetzt jetzt unterwegs wäre und du warst gerade in Disneyland und du hast es noch zu deinem Pirates of the Caribbean ride geschafft und dann gehen wir nach Hause und du kostest eine U-Bahn, würde ich glaube ich so hinten meine Hand auf dein Schulterblatt legen, designalisieren in diesem schweren Moment, ich bin da, alles gut, kein Problem, was hier gerade passiert, wir kriegen das zusammen hin, würde dann dieses Tätscheln machen und dann loslassen. Ich streiche
in der Weise ein bisschen
beschrieben, aber und da,
in dem Moment habe ich mich aber ein bisschen allein gelassen gefühlt,
aber er hat quasi so sich
unangenehm auch, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie das unangenehm war, weil du bist ja in der Notlage,
während du da in Paris reinkotzt,
auch Paris, keine schöne Stadt,
also wenn du, keine Ahnung, in einer hässlichen Stadt, New York, glaube ich, würde es nicht so auffallen oder so, aber Paris, da fällt man schon auf als Fremdkörper, der gerade nicht in diese ... Da fällt Erbrochenes auf, das stimmt schon, ja. Merkwilge Stadt. Ich dachte aber auch, Wien wäre noch schlimmer. In Wien geschickt es sich nicht zu kotzen. Nein, das gehört sich nicht. In Paris, glaube ich, haben die das schon mal gesehen. So, keine Ahnung, New York normal. Ja.
Kenne ich der Rede wert. Ach, krass. Ja, das war mein Disneyland-Tag. War sehr rückblickend nicht viel geschafft und es war sehr leer. Es war eigentlich der perfekte Tag. Es war dieses perfekte Freizeitparkwetter, also es war trocken, trotzdem nicht zu warm, nicht zu kalt. Es war super leer, mitten in der Woche. Ich habe überall nur maximal zehn Minuten angestanden. Es war eigentlich der lächerlich perfekte Tag dafür. Leider hat mir das Essen vom Vortag, was auch immer, schlicht nicht die Rechnung gemacht. Ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben so schlimmen Durchfall. Passt auf euch auf. Nehmt da irgendwie eure Magenmineralien und nehmt ein Durchfallmittel. Weil ich glaube, es ist nicht so ohne, diese Erkrankung. Hat mich ziemlich hart getroffen.
Da muss man vielleicht auch vernünftig sein und einfach nicht hingehen. Klar, das ist für dich natürlich hart, zu sagen, ich verzichte auf Parents of the Caribbean.
60 Euro, da bin ich viel zu knickirig für. Ich würde niemals 60 Euro verfallen lassen.
Naja, ja, krass. Ja, und dann, ich glaube, für mich war es nicht so schlimm, in dem Moment da in der Oberstation zu kotzen, weil du bist halt, dein Körper ist in einer Notsituation, für die andere Person ist es, glaube ich, schlimmer. Ja. Weil die so, oh Gott, oh Jesus Christus. Weil du musst ja die Blicke, du kriegst ja die Blicke ab. Ja, klar, warum tätschelst du jetzt nicht? Den verachtungsvollen Blick, aber du kriegst auch den, was ist denn bei euch los, Blick ab, den ich ja gar nicht abbekomme, weil mein Blick gerne in den Müller immer gerichtet ist. Ja, aber mittlerweile bin ich wieder fit und alles wieder gut. Wow, Mensch, aber du bist aber auch bis aufs Letzte für deine Freizeitpark-Leidenschaft. Du, Freizeitpark-Reviews schreiben Sie nicht von allein. Ja, ich habe auch das Gefühl, der Podcast wandelt sich, also vom Verschwörungspodcast jetzt langsam zum Freizeitpark.
Die einen sagen eine gute Richtung. Die anderen sagen, es geht bergab, die anderen sagen, es geht bergauf. So ist das nun mal. Die anderen sagen, es ist ein großer Looping, ist die Frage. Aber es gibt ja, glaube ich, auch ein paar langweilige Sachen, die man in Disneyland machen kann, so entspannte Sachen. Da gibt es hier dieses fantastische Video von Jenny Nicholson, die sagt Top 10 boring things to do in Disneyland. und da gibt es ja eine Streichelzoo.
Eine Streichelzoo mit den Ziegen.
Wo sind einfach Ziegen, einfach Ziegen. Du kannst einfach in Multimillionen in den All geschossen werden in Space Mountain oder Ziegen. So, du kannst da entscheiden. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das immer noch gibt, der verändert sich ja auch mit Star Wars und so, aber es gibt auch wirklich langweilige Sachen. Er verändert sich nicht mit Star Wars. Du wirst einfach so in randomem Poster auf Jules Verne geklebt. Ja, Ziegen oder der People Mover irgendwie, wo so eine ganz langsame Bahn, so eine U-Bahn, die über den Leuten fährt, aber halt ganz langsam, so um von A nach B zu kommen. Genau. Und ja, viele tolle Sachen, also da kann man auch viele leben. Und auch viele machen, wenn es einem vielleicht nicht so gut geht, wenn man keinen Bock hat, durchgeschüttelt zu werden. Jeder von uns, der schon mal Rollercoaster, Tycoon gespielt hat, weiß ja, dass es so was geben muss. Die billigen Attraktionen, die das Gesamtbild des Parks so aussehen lassen. Ja, auch für die ganz kleinen Kinder oder so. Die Jugendlichen gehen dann irgendwie rüber in die Achterbahn und dann die ganz kleinen Kinder, da kannst du dann vor so eine Ziege setzen. Es war horrormässig der Tag, wirklich. Es ist auch rückwinkend nur noch so ein grosser Überthorn. Es ist so verrückt, weil ich erinnere mich auch an Disneyland Paris und da habe ich auch so einen Hut bekommen, so einen Pluto-Hut, so diesen gelben Pluto-Hut mit den Augen vorne, so einen Käppi und dann aber die Ohren links und rechts, Pluto's Ohren links und rechts runtergehangen. Und dann hatte ich den ganzen Tag an als Kind im Disneyland und hatte durchfallend wenigstens schlecht und ich wollte danach auch den Hut nicht mehr aufsetzen.
Ich stelle mir auch sehr gut vor, dieses strahlend, weil alles ist ja so strahlend
fröhlich da und nervig
fröhlich, auch so aufdringlich fröhlich.
Und dann hast du halt diesen lustigen Hut
auf mit den grossen wachen Augen und
darunter ist einfach so ein halbtotes,
bleiches, zerstörtes
Kindergesicht, das einfach sagt,
ich bin am schönsten Ort der Welt, mir geht
schlecht. Und diese Orte sind nicht dafür
gemacht, dass es einem schlecht geht. Überhaupt nicht. Und ich habe
und dann bleiches, zerstörtes Kindergesicht, das einfach sagt, ich bin am schönsten Ort der Welt, mir geht schlecht. Diese Orte sind nicht dafür gemacht, dass es einem schlecht geht. Überhaupt nicht. Und ich habe danach auch echt einfach Hemmungen gehabt, diesen Hut nochmal aufzusetzen, weil ich den so verbunden habe mit der Krankheit, dass ich den nicht mehr aufsetzen wollte. Obwohl ich einen Pluto-Hut hatte, der eigentlich richtig cool war. Ich mag auch jetzt, ja, nee, ich bin auch froh, dass es mir jetzt Pirates nicht komplett kaputt gemacht hat, aber da, also wenn man mich gesehen hätte, wie ich da rumfahre, und ich wollte das aufnehmen. Ich hätte dir so ein Bild, so ein Foto kaufen sollen bei der Achterbahn, wie alle einfach, und du völlig fertig, einfach hältst dich fest an dem Bügel. oder einfach aber ganz viele von den Bildern meinen Tag in Disneyland Resort Paris und dann einfach zehn Bilder, wo du in verschiedenen Achterbahnen immer bleicher und kranker aussehen kannst. Dann hast du so einen großen Fleck auf dem T-Shirt. Ja, da habe ich mich das erste Mal übergeben und dann das zweite Mal. Ja, vor allem, also der Pirates of the Caribbean Ride, den ich unbedingt noch mitnehmen wollte, da war halt schon körperlich komplett am Ende bei mir. Es war nur noch noch auf Überleben bei meinem Körper aus, aber ich wollte unbedingt noch den da rein. Und das ist ja keine Achterbahn, ne? Das ist ja, du fährst ja auf Booten, fährst du da rum. Langsam, es ist ein Slow Ride. Aber halt nicht boring, weil halt die ganze Szenerie voll cool ist. Und jetzt gibt's ja ja auch, du fährst durch einen Part, direkt am Anfang, wo das Pirates of the Caribbean Restaurant ist. Das heißt, du hast ganz viele Menschen, die an diesen Tischen sitzen und auf diese Bahn gucken. Und jetzt sahen die da an irgendeinem Punkt mich, der fällt ja auf, weil ich bin ja groß. Ich gucke aber alle hinweg, saß in diesem Boot und mein Kopf hat gesagt, also mein Gesichtsausdruck hat gesagt, glaube ich, hat denen verschiedene Signale gegeben.
Erstes Signal One war, mir geht es richtig, richtig schlecht. Bleich, ich bin kurz davor, mich zu übergeben und Durchfall zu haben. Und mir fehlen wichtige Nährstoffe im Körper, mir schwindel ich, ich muss kotzen, ich will hier raus und muss überleben. Und der zweite war, ich bin der grösste Pirates of the Caribbean Fan und ich will alles aufnehmen, was ich hier sehe. Das heißt, ich habe wild rumgeguckt, um natürlich gar nichts zu verpassen. Also wenn man von außen meine Silhouette war, die eines aufgeregten Zwölfjährigen, der alle Informationen aufnehmen will. Und ach, guck mal da oben, der auch immer gerufen wird, oh, da ist Gips.
Oh, da ist Captain Jack.
Oh, wir sind in Tortuga.
Diese Sachen habe ich gesagt, halt mit dem Gesichtsausdruck eines Stopfers von Dead Man's Chest mässig.
Ich finde das so gut, aber auch, wie das für deinen Körper auch wirken muss.
Weil ich glaube, du bist einfach für deinen Körper der dümmste Mensch der Welt, dein Körper signalisiert dir, Hilfe, Hilfe, wir dehydrieren, uns geht es schlecht, du bist krank und Stefan sagt, ich gehe in eine Geisterbahn und der Körper sagt, Hilfe, ein Geist, oh wir sind krank, oh nein, bitte hier raus, oh nein, Hilfe, was ist das? und du einfach, ich gehe jetzt in eine Geisterbahn, ich will mich jetzt erschrecken, ich will jetzt auch noch Angst haben.
Der Körper völlig überfordert einfach, weil es überhaupt nicht was los ist. Panik, Adrenalin, still, was ist das, ein Werwolf, Hilfe, ein Werwolf! Ja, ich dachte, wenn ich den jetzt überfordere, wenn manche Zahnschmerzen hat und du kneifst dich irgendwie woanders hin, an den Arm oder sowas, hast du so kurz keine Zahnschmerzen mehr? Gut, das ist eine Kettreaktion, die muss man halt auch aufrechterhalten.
Du musst ja dann immer mehr...
Deswegen war ich nach dem Haunted House dann in der Pirates of the Caribbean nach der
Bahn. Also, ich hab schon versucht, da irgendwie
Reize zu setzen, die so ein bisschen ablenken,
aber mein Körper war, glaube ich, irgendwann so
abgeturnt von mir als Mensch.
Was ist los mit dir? Wir müssen hier überleben.
Da will ich aber auch sagen, hast du eigentlich einen kompletten Schaden?
Geh einfach nach Hause, leg dich hin
und fahr nicht in eine Piratenstadt. Ja, schon jetzt sind maximal viele Eindrücke noch gesammelt. Alles so was mitgenommen, was geht. Nervig. Wow, aber ich bin froh, dass du es überlebt hast. Kacktag. Ja, naja, gut. Was eine doofe Policy, also da große Kritik. Mein Rufer, also Auszug für Disneyland Paris, mein Tripadvisor ist im Keller, weil lasst Leute, die krank sind, doch bitte das Ticket umdatieren. Ja, die wollen doch auch nicht kranke Leute in ihrem Park haben oder die kotzen hin und stecken andere Leute an. Ja, das könnte ja jeder machen. Vielleicht hatten sie mal die Policy und dann hat es einfach wirklich jeder gemacht und der Park war jeden Tag leer und die die haben gesagt, das kann doch nicht sein, warum sind denn
alle krank?
Ja, aber die haben ja bezahlt, ich verstehe gar nicht, was haben die denn gegen
leeren Park? Auch das ist ja was Gutes.
Meistens sollten ja aktiv daran arbeiten,
generell verstehe ich, dass das alles
nicht überholt ist mit dem Anstellen und sowas.
Leute, man kann sich doch digital
anstellen, das hat der Europapark jetzt ganz clever gemacht,
findet ihr im Stephans Europapark
Update auch in meinem Newsletter, aber da kann man sich digital anstellen, was natürlich wahnsinnig clever ist. Dass man sich da digital anstellt und dann, wenn man einen Termin hat, gehst du hin. Und dann kannst du ohne anstellen hin. Das geht ja. Ach so, okay. Und dann dürfen nur Leute rein, die dann diese Bestellung haben auf dem Handy. Ja, weil ich verstehe nicht mehr, warum man sich aktiv anstellen muss. Man hat ja keinen Sinn mehr, wenn ihr ein Handy in der Tasche hat. Du kannst dich ja quasi überall anstellen, wenn du dran bist, bist du dran. Genial. Ja, stimmt, du gehörst natürlich auch ein bisschen dazu. Ja, also es war sehr schlimm. Die Vorfreude, das Warten. Es war sehr schlimm. Aber ich hab mich noch nie so gegruselt in diesem Haunted House, weil ich keine Angst hatte jetzt vor den Geistern per se, sondern dass ich da reinkotze. Also es war so ein hoffentlich überstehe ich das hier. Du hattest mehr Angst vor dem Toilette-Geschlossenschild als vor dem schlimmsten Geist, ja. Ja, vor allem bin ich mal als Kind, ich war mit fünf Jahren jetzt zum Mal in Paris, auch mit so einem grossen Hut auf, mit großen Augen bin ich da rumgelaufen und ich erinnere mich auch, dass es mir da so ein bisschen schlecht geht. Also vielleicht macht diese Stadt einen einfach auch krank. Ja, das kann sein. Als deutsch. Ja, das ist die Rache. Die späte Rache der Franzosen. Die geben dir immer die schlechten Fische dann zu essen. Und da weiß ich noch, dass ich da auch stecken geblieben war in dem Geisterschloss. Weil da, und dann war dann so eine, diesen Raum gab es auch noch, wo dann eine Wahrsagerin in dieser Wahrsagekugel spricht. Und da fährt man auf diesen langsamen Wagenfässer dann da rum und da ist mein Wagen stecken geblieben. Und dann sei es ja mit meiner Mom für eine Dreiviertelstunde in diesem stockfinsteren Haus, wo mir auffiel, weil ich habe das als Wagen Traum in der Runde gehabt und habe nicht gestanden, weil ich wusste nicht mehr, was sie sagt. Nein, hat Französisch gesprochen. Das heißt, du hast eine dreiviertel Stunde lang, habe ich halt diese Wahrsage Kugel mit so einem weirden Lasereffekt zugehört beim Sprechen, habe nicht verstanden, was sie gesagt hat und es ging halt nicht weiter. Das wusste ich noch. Und dann war ich da jetzt mit meinem Magenproblem, kam wieder in diesen Raum gefahren und hat gesagt, bitte jetzt nicht hier stecken bleiben.
Das war so traumatisch für mich, da jetzt wieder mit den Magenproblemen hängen zu bleiben. Es ist eine wirkliche Geisterbahn mit wirklichen Kindheitstraumata, die wirklich wieder getriggert werden. Wahnsinn. Nee, aber genau. Also deswegen kann ich jetzt nicht, sorry, dass jetzt meine Review so ausfällt. Es sind auch die Begleitumstände, klar, das muss natürlich ein objektiver Kritiker auch ausblenden können, aber du bist einfach mit Herz und Seele in dem Thema verankert, deswegen gehört das natürlich immer dazu. Ich bin gespannt, was als nächstes kommt bei dir, vielleicht dann doch mal in der Escape Room, bin ich mal gespannt, falls ihr da Vorschläge habt, schickt sie gerne an Stefan oder postet sie auf Reddit und ansonsten wünschen wir euch eine fantastische Woche, haut rein, schaut mal bei Reddit vorbei und überlegt, ob der UFO-Club was für euch ist.
Werbefreie Folgen, alle Folgen könnt ihr werbefrei hören und auch schon immer freitags, einen Tag früher.
Also, falls ihr da Bock drauf habt, schaut mal auf Patreon vorbei.
Ansonsten, habt eine schöne Woche.
Hab eine schöne Woche, macht's gut. Wir heben ab, mach's gut.